now we're talking of course about how
different countries are tackling the
virus and South Korea has been widely
praised for its response they've seen
10,000 cases and 214 deaths still very
sad of course but nothing on the scale
seen here or in many other countries so
what is the secret to their relative
success we can talk now to South Korea's
ambassador to the UK and a park thank
you very much for being with us today
now sir South Korea was one of the first
countries to report a significant
outbreak of kovat 19 but a relatively
small number of people have died in the
country compared to elsewhere what
lessons can others learn from South
Korea well first a happy Easter to
everybody I if I may I'd like to start
here by paying tribute to two or
excellent wonderful medical staff and
volunteers who work very hard to save
lives across the UK and I would like to
also share the Prime Minister a very
quick and full recovery on behalf of
Korean government and the people our
colleague Korea as has successfully made
the curb flattened but we know that as
still it's not it now it hasn't come to
end yet so we have to keep vigilant but
yes said Korean Eric Hayes seems quite
as successful even though it is not the
only perfect models for all other
countries to follow but we can share
that the lessons we learned the main
lessons we learned is testing is very
important so at the beginning of out the
break we encouraged the medical research
institutes to develop the testicles and
we gave very quick approval and we also
promoted the Korean companies to produce
the test kit at the largest scale so we
build up a stock file and it was the
foundation of mass
Casta so our strategy was test trace and
the treat and it worked so far it's
interesting you tested over half a
million people that's around 200,000
more than the UK despite having a
smaller population do you think the UK
should be testing more people so far we
have conducted the more than 1/2 million
tests so in terms of population per
capita Korea is that the highest that
the biggest a testing country in the
world and you know all the air detection
is very critical for right time
treatment so early detection through
tracing we tracked down all suspected
acacias
all contacts of the confirmed cases and
we utilized their advanced technology
ICT technology like credit card
transaction record history CCTV footage
and mobile phone GPS data so we traced
all suspected cases and all contacts and
we put those people into the right
medical facilities for all the medical
intervention that's how we had capture
the fatality rate rate very low around
there less than 2% interesting to hear
how important contact tracing has been
but you were just saying you know the
eview CCTV you've used GPS data from
phones you've used credit card
transactions is there a concern there
about privacy well of course there has
been concerns expressed there however a
year five years ago when we hit by
Marisa we introduced a new law to make a
tracing easier in case of a new outbreak
of infectious disease and the lowest a
place to Warrick Center we can collect
information and
we can use it the what are the limits
and how we deal with those information
to protect a privacy so we used
information to track down but we made
only relevant and anonymous information
to the we disclose that those relevant
and anonymous information to the public
and we try to balance public healthcare
concern and the privacy and you know
people in Korea they were willing to you
they're willing to compromise their
privacy to some extent in order for the
sake of a great good for the sake of
public health and I think that is civic
awareness one other thing I want to ask
you about is face masks because many
people in South Korea we're at face
masks to protect themselves and others
from coronavirus that isn't officially
recommended in the UK do you think it
should be well every country has
different challenges and different
background so is we I can't say a UK
government should or should not but the
Korean government made the official
recommendation to wear masks because
based on our experience and our research
we know that the mask helps reduce the
risk of being affected and also
transmitting you know taking into
account that that there are many cases
that confirm the cases with no symptoms
so you can spray the virus without
knowing it so we know that at wearing
masks it doesn't completely prevent
pinger from being infected or from
transmitting but it helps okay and just
finally and I want to ask about quite a
concerning story around ninety one
patients here class has been cured of
corona virus in South Korea have tested
positive again that's according to the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention does that mean that we might
not get an archive it 19 or
or does that mean that the tests are not
reliable we are not quite sure but the
test itself is quite reliable but we do
not know enough about this virus so
after being cured and you are diagnosed
that you're fully recovered the pastille
there is possibility that the virus are
alive in your body and is deactivated so
we are in the process of learning about
the virus in a more complete way okay
and thank you so much for coming on the
program this morning sharing some of the
lessons that the world can learn from
South Korea much appreciated
before closing I'd like to touch upon
one important issue which is racial
discrimination
unfortunately we witnessed some
incidents of fears and a phobia or
racial discrimination targeting Asians
and it's not acceptable and we are
living a civilized the world this is
time to show solidarity and support to
each other by doing that we can overcome
this pandemic very important final
message there as well and something I'm
sure that we can all get behind
absolutely right thank you